saint senier de beuvron fait de la
résistance ce petit village du
nord-ouest de la france a récemment été
choisi par l'entreprise space x objectif
pour la compagnie américaine il
développer les infrastructures servant à
relier ces satellites et développer son
réseau internet haut débit à destination
du monde entier le village qui possède
déjà la fibre constitue un lieu
d'implantation idéal pour la firme du
richissime elon musk problème le projet
semble très loin de faire l'unanimité au
sein de la population
ce projet donc on l'a refusée parce
qu'on a vu à manque d'information au
niveau de la santé la santé humaine mais
aussi de la santé animale car nous
sommes quand même dans un milieu très
rurale et avec beaucoup d'agriculteurs
autour de nous on sait que ça peut jouer
sur le sur la production laitière ça
peut diminuer la production laitière et
malheureusement visuellement ça ne se
voit pas donc on a et on n'a pas de
recul pour savoir ce qui est bon et ce
qui est grave au bouquet pour les
animaux quoi une zone rurale de 350
habitants de nombreuses exploitations
une activité agricole incontournable le
projet a de quoi inquiéter les habitants
les informations sur les effets des
ondes sur la santé et la production
locale demeure trop floue aux yeux de ce
conseiller régional c'est chaud
électromagnétiques pose déjà des
interrogations aux élevages qui sont
déjà beaucoup impacter les dom terrestre
qui serait implantée dans les sous sols
en zone humide avec des nappes
phréatiques de surfaces ou des nappes
profondes à quelques mètres des cours
d'eau ce sont des choses qui méritent
d'être expertisée starling souhaitait
acquérir trois hectares et y installer
plusieurs données lectrique ainsi que
des antennes de trois mètres de haut
selon les écologistes
pour l'heure ce projet à mi chemin entre
avranches et fougères a recueilli
l'unanimité contre lui au conseil
municipal du village
mais la firme d'outre-atlantique
disposerait de deux autres options pour
implanter ses activités sur le
territoire dans le nord et en gironde